salut à tous Comment ça va alors
regardez aujourd'hui apple a présenté
ces nouveaux iPhone alors l'idée c'est
pas de vous faire une vidéo pour vous
récapituler les nouveautés parce qu'on
en parle tous les côtés mais c'est
essayer de comprendre un peu qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé ce que c'est intéressant
et quels sont les trucs qui ont vraiment
du sens et on va regarder les prix parce
que les prix ont quand même augmenter on
va pas se mentir au niveau de ses
différents iPhone alors on va commencer
par les iPhone 14 iPhone 14 plus on
aurait cru iPhone 14 max mais non iPhone
14 plus et puis on continuera par la
gamme pro et puis je vous ferai une
autre vidéo pour vous parler des Apple
watch parce que là il y a aussi la très
très grosse nouveauté et c'est en mode
du steak allez on y va tout de suite on
commence par un petit générique
[Musique]
les iPhone sont arrivés ça y est ils
sont sortis alors c'est vrai que les
rumeurs elles ont avaient déjà quasiment
tout dit on savait quasiment tout alors
pour autant de trois petites choses à
venir voir à droite à gauche notamment
un format beaucoup plus grand ça y est
il peut la laisser tomber sur ma mini je
crois que vraiment le format mini c'est
un truc qui était plutôt sympa l'idée de
se dire non mais attendez les gens ont
encore envie de petits formats les gens
encore ont envie de petits smartphone et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui ça devient
vraiment un truc trop niche que ça
n'intéresse plus suffisamment Apple pour
autant de niche ça peut être intéressant
pour des constructeurs comme Asus qui
arrivent avec un zenfone neuf avec un
petit format ou là pour le coup c'est un
sens parce que peu pour exister au
niveau des smartphones il faut être dans
une niche mais pour Apple qui vend des
tonnes de smartphones les produits de
niches ça intéresse beaucoup moins alors
moi je trouve qu'il m'a vraiment surpris
ce que disait les rumeurs et je voulais
pas y croire c'est de se dire qu'Apple à
garder la puce à 15 bionique à 15
bionique est sorti dans les iPhones
l'année dernière alors il vous disent
attendez c'est là 15 bionique mais c'est
pas vraiment la quinze bionique enfin
pas assez de l'année dernière on l'a
retravaillé on a amélioré des choses en
fait ce qu'on a tout de suite avec cette
à 15 bionique c'est une à 15 bionique
qui vient se positionner entre la 15
Buddy des iPhones et la 16 bionique des
iPhone 14 pro donc on est pile poil au
milieu au niveau de la performance donc
on vient garder quand même pas mal de
performances on améliore un petit peu
mais on va pas aussi loin alors je peux
voir si c'est des questions de coût
c'est une nouvelle stratégies ce qu'il
fallait vraiment venir différencier la
gamme professionnelle pour que les gens
aillent dessus j'en sais rien en tout
cas ils ont fait ce choix là alors très
honnêtement déjà la puce à 15 Bonnie ça
marchait vachement bien donc j'ai aucun
doute que la A15 bionique pas la plus
nouvelle génération marche mieux c'est
sûr par rapport à paddle smartphone
d'autant plus et vous le savez ici chez
Apple on aligne les planètes c'est tout
qui marche très très bien chez eux c'est
comme il maîtrise tout le matériel il
maîtrise tout le logiciel quoi qu'il se
passe ça fonctionne du feu de Dieu donc
ici pas de mauvaise surprise alors le
truc moi qui m'intéresse regardez je
vous le montre ici c'est ce qu'on va
voir au niveau d'un écran plus grand il
vous le disent on a effectivement
l'iPhone standard l'iPhone 14 et
l'iPhone 14 plus c'est marrant parce
qu'en fait le format plus il avait été
abandonné il y a quelques années c'était
quoi c'était l'iPhone 8 dernier iPhone 8
iPhone 8 plus et après on arrive avec
différentes dénominations jusqu'à
trouver depuis deux ans la version max
pour les très grands écrans et ça me est
logique qu'on appelle l'iPhone 14 max
pour avoir une cohérence de gamme iPhone
14 iPhone 14 max iPhone 14 pro il fait
14 pro max non voilà on différencie
vraiment cette fois-ci la gamme pro de
la gamme standard elle est vraiment
extrêmement différenciée donc on est sur
l'iPhone 14 et l'iPhone 14 plus pour
autant entre les modèles pro et les
modèles un peu plus standard on a les
mêmes diagonales d'écran 6,1 pouces 6,7
pouces de tous les côtés on a dû au lait
de tous les côtés de très jolies dalles
de tous les côtés vous allez voir que ce
qui différencie aujourd'hui c'est plus
la qualité de la dalle c'est vraiment
l'encoche et puis la dynamique Island
mais ça on en parle pour le modèle
professionnel dans quelques instants
nouveauté qui est vachement intéressant
ça ça me plaît beaucoup parce que vous
savez Apple il va être vraiment mettre
la sécurité le confort et le fait
d'apporter de vrais services aux
utilisateurs on le voit au travers des
Apple Watch et on le voit également au
travers des iPhone et là le fait de
mettre une détection des accidents qui
va appeler les secours pour vous je
trouve ça cool d'autant plus que ça va
fonctionner ensemble si vous avez une
Apple Watch et si vous avez votre iPhone
alors il faut que votre APPLE watch
derrière génération et votre iPhone
également mais ils vont le voir et ils
vont venir contacter les secours pour
vous pour être secouru en envoyant votre
position donc ça c'est plutôt bien
est-ce que vous avez un accident il la
mettra son urgence et si jamais ça
fonctionne pas il va venir appeler
directement autre nouveauté que je
trouve vachement intéressant au niveau
de la vidéo ils ont fait un gros focus
l'année dernière au niveau des iPhone 13
sur la vidéo et ils avaient lancé
notamment le mode cinématique où vous
venez faire le focus d'un côté de
l'autre c'était plutôt bien mais c'était
comme 1080p c'était [ __ ] et là ça y
est alors peut-être que ça vient de la
nouvelle puce A15 d'entre deux
générations j'en sais rien mais en tout
cas cette fois-ci on arrive en 4K à 24
images par seconde donc on va un peu
plus loin alors moi qui filme en 4K à 30
images par seconde il va manquer un
petit peu voyez mais bon je pense ça va
être quand même plutôt pas mal donc ça
ça me plaît bien il y a un autre mode
qu'ils ont présenté également c'est le
mode action cam ça va venir stabiliser
davantage donc lorsque vous allez courir
une vraie grosse stabilisation ça veut
dire pousser davantage la stabilisation
électronique mais pour quelqu'un comme
moi je vous assure que c'est quand même
vachement bien autre truc mais je trouve
pas sur leur site tout de suite c'est à
dire c'est la connexion satellitaire
c'est le SOS par le satellite en fait
c'est un truc dont les rumeurs faisaient
déjà état c'est-à-dire qu'en fait votre
smartphone et bien lorsque vous êtes sur
sérieux au milieu de la montagne au
milieu de la pampa paumée et bien vous
allez pouvoir prendre votre smartphone
ils ont fait un vrai travail un logiciel
ou vos smartphones va savoir que le sata
satellite par là par là par là face aux
satellite on voit le satellite et lui il
va contacter comme service d'urgence
alors vous allez leur écrire par message
en fait c'est très très synthétique
voilà ce qui m'est arrivé si ça ça soit
le service d'urgence en face peut venir
recevoir les messages communiqués avec
vous et vous enverra les secours soit et
bien ils ont un espèce de de hub
centralisé où ils vont récupérer et ils
vont envoyer les informations au service
d'urgence pour venir vous secourir donc
l'idée est vachement cool vachement bien
pour autant on va pas passer des coups
de fil satellitaires mais pour des SMS
pour avoir de la sécurité derrière je
trouve ça extrêmement malin et très très
bien fait ici alors les modèles pro ont
eu droit aussi à leur mise à jour avec
la dynamic Island la dynamic Island
c'est quoi et bien si vous n'avez plus
ce grand facidy là qui venait vous
manger votre écran comme on a sur les
modèles 14 et 14 plus on a une espèce de
grande bulle qui vit au milieu comme une
petite île donc il s'appelle ça l'île
dynamique la dynamic Island qu'on va
pouvoir utiliser c'est très malin ce
qu'a fait Apple ici c'est-à-dire de
différentes manières pour montrer plein
de choses des notifications et si ça
regardez alors je vais vous le montrer
ils ont fait un jeux de mots là sur leur
site pro le modèle Pro il est plus ultra
alors je trouve ça bien vu que déjà on
parle de l'iPhone 14 plus c'est pas de
l'iPhone 14 max mais il est plus ultra
donc j'ouvre vraiment sur les mots alors
on va passer à les finitions c'est pas
le sujet aujourd'hui c'est surtout ça
moi qui m'intéresse c'est voyez en fait
sur cette petite encoche et ils arrivent
ici à moduler à changer s'adapte
complètement que vous branchiez vous
écouteurs que vous voyez le niveau de
charge que vous voyez votre musique que
vous ayez un timer que ça vous mette le
GPS que ça vous mette j'ai noté plein
plein de trucs qu'on peut venir faire
ici je trouve ça juste hyper malin sur
la charge le GPS de timer on les appelle
et un buzz enfin bref c'est très cool ça
vient s'ouvrir c'est la dynamique Island
et je trouve ça mais tellement bien vu
parce que en fait on vient utiliser
cette petit truc noir pour en créer
quelque chose d'intéressant au niveau de
l'expérience utilisateur alors il reste
toujours quelque chose attention on
n'est pas ici sur une caméra sous écran
on n'est pas sur des capteurs invisibles
il y a toujours ce truc là mais je
trouve que ce qui propose Apple ici
c'est tellement malin alors pour autant
les tailles d'écran sont exactement les
mêmes que vous avez sur les 14 et 14 +
c'est-à-dire du 6,1 et du 6,7 pouces un
que je trouve malin qui sont venus
mettre on a l'impression c'est toujours
un peu la révolution chez Apple parce
que ça arrive c'est le always on display
vous savez c'est le fait d'avoir tout
afficher sur votre écran lorsque votre
écran n'est pas utilisé vous le posez
sur une table et comme ça vous avez
quand même un affichage alors regardez
il vous montre tout vous avez l'heure la
météo vous avez des infos bref
différentes choses assez intéressantes
alors en fait ça ils arrivent à le faire
grâce à technologie ltpo qui permet
d'avoir un taux de rafraîchissement
variable après ici le promotion où on
descend jusqu'à un Hertz en fait c'est
les Hertz c'est le nombre d'images que
vous avez par seconde en 1 Hertz vous
avez une image par seconde ce qui fait
que ça va pas consommer énormément et
comme vous êtes sur duolet tous les
pixels noirs sont des pixels éteint on
vient diminuer un peu la luminosité
alors forcément ça a toujours consommer
davantage mais vu que derrière on a la
nouvelle puce à 16 bionique vu que on a
une optimisation complètement logiciel
et compagnie bref on vient optimiser
pour que ça ne vienne pas taper dans la
batterie de votre smartphone alors je
connais beaucoup de smartphone qui ont
du always on display avec juste leur pas
grand chose Apple a fait le choix quand
même de mettre un quota un peu plus
graphique un peu plus joli c'est Apple
on peut faire un truc un peu au rabais
et bon dans et je trouve ça plutôt pas
mal alors il vous le marque une
autonomie d'une journée et il se mouille
pas parce que aujourd'hui je suis
content de votre smartphone c'est
l'autonomie d'un jour et demi voire deux
jours alors il marque une journée ça
sera plus bien évidemment alors après ça
va dépendre de vous de vos usages une
fois de plus mais là ou Apple est venu
frapper un peu plus fort si au niveau de
ses capteurs ça c'était la rumeur qui le
disait aussi c'est à dire que on allait
avoir un capteur de 48 mégapixels et si
on écoute Apple c'est un peu la
révolution vous voyez le capteur de 48
mégapixels alors qu'il y a des
smartphones dans lesquels les capteurs
de 48 50 108 mégapixels sont là depuis
déjà relativement longtemps et encore
plus de mégapixels dans les smartphones
qui vont arriver donc bon est-ce que il
faut plus de mégapixels pour améliorer
la qualité la réponse est pas
nécessairement oui la réponse peut être
non il faut surtout un capteur de bonne
qualité il faut aligner les planètes il
faut derrière qu'il y a un vrai
traitement logiciel de bonne qualité et
si comme le matériel est logiciel est
signé Apple on noter que ça marchera
bien en tout cas on vérifiera ça ce qui
vous dise en tout cas c'est que ils font
enfin la fameuse technologie du pixel
binning c'est à dire qu'en fait il va
regrouper 4 pixels pour sortir un seul
gros pixel qui va capter plus de lumière
donc des photos beaucoup plus lumineuses
aux conditions de faible luminosité
[Musique]
son contenu en 30 images par seconde ça
a quand même bien que c'est quelques
petites images qui me manquent ça
viendrait quand même maximiser un peu
l'expérience alors on vous le montre
également le mode action stabilisateur
intégré Hollywood peut trembler ça c'est
cool aussi donc ça je dois très très
bien la puce bien évidemment est mise à
jour ici c'est la as bionique qui va
aller plus loin bon bah ça te paraît
normal en général la surprise c'est plus
sur les iPhone 14 que sur les iPhone 14
pro l'autre nouveauté que je trouve
vraiment intéressant c'est qu'en fait
Apple je pense pas peut-être la première
fois que garde autant d'iPhone au
catalogue iPhone 12 l'iPhone se deuxième
génération l'iPhone 13 l'iPhone 14 les
iPhone 14 pro donc vous avez quand même
deux générations antérieures avec
l'iPhone 13 qui est un très très bon
smartphone et l'iPhone 12 qui est aussi
un excellent smartphone alors après ça
va être un petit peu déconnant au niveau
des tarifs parce que je vais vous le
montrer dans quelques instants on va
regarder déjà l'iPhone 14 regardez les
tarifs l'iPhone 14 est disponible à
partir de Ferro alors qu'avant l'iPhone
13 de la même config en 128 Go on était
à 909 €. donc là on a passé la barre des
1000 euros on prend quand même 110 euros
de plus dans la tête et si vous regardez
sur l'iPhone alors on a pas de
référentiel entre l'iPhone mini et
l'iPhone 14 plus donc bon on va passer
un peu le truc l'iPhone 14 pro on
commence à 329 euros alors qu'avant sur
l'iPhone 13 pro j'ai mes fiches on était
à 1159 euros on a pris 200 balles de
plus 200 euros de plus c'est quand même
relativement conséquent ici et sur la
F14 pro max on commence à
1479 € alors qu'avant ont commencé sur
l'iPhone 13 pro max à 1259 € on a pris
220 € de plus au niveau du tarif il y a
une génération plus une certitude mais
par contre on voit que l'inflation est
là elle est vraiment là et si vous
regardez on passe les 2000 euros pour un
iPhone version 1 To
2129 euros c'est très cher alors
qu'avant on était à 1800 et quelques
euros on montait pas aussi haut là quand
même les tarifs s'envolent et si vous
regardez les tarifs je vous ai mis un
petit comparatif l'iPhone 12 il commence
à 809 €, ça quand même vachement cher
l'iPhone 13 909 euros et l'iPhone 14
1019 euros alors que si vous regardez
sur n'importe quel bonne crèmerie sur du
reconditionné un iPhone 12 elle touche
autour des 500 et quelques euros est-ce
que ça vaut le coup aujourd'hui de
mettre 809 € sur un smartphone qui a
déjà deux ans je suis pas convaincu un
iPhone 13 c'est pareil vous allez
remonter un an en arrière vous allez le
payer 10 euros de moins qu'un iPhone 14
je trouve que le delta est énorme je
trouve ça beaucoup trop cher ça c'est le
prix auquel il est sorti ce smartphone
il y a un an pourquoi est-ce qu'il
continue à le laisser à ce prix là
aujourd'hui je trouve ça honnêtement
beaucoup trop cher un peu indécent
d'ailleurs il l'aurait proposé à 89 € et
l'iPhone 12 à 700 €. j'aurais dit là ça
va c'est intéressant là ça reste quand
même beaucoup trop cher non à ce prix là
ils peuvent pas nous le proposer
aujourd'hui au même tarif c'est pas
possible on peut pas dire un an après ce
smartphone il est au même prix c'est pas
possible alors soit ils ont pas tout mis
à jour j'espère je croise les doigts
mais sinon ça ça me paraît mais
tellement déconnant tellement déconnant
pour finir un dernier petit truc
qu'Apple nous a dit je trouvais assez
rigolo c'est qu'en fait ils ont dit ils
ont montré un petit tableau en disant ok
regardez nous aujourd'hui on en est là
en terme de performance au niveau de
notre puce à 16 bionique on en est là et
aujourd'hui si vous regardez le meilleur
des concurrents il arrive à peine à
concurrencer la puce qu'on a sorti en
2019 il concurrence à peine ils sont au
niveau de nous il y a trois ans en
arrière donc en fait ça veut dire et
Apple vous dit ça ils ont trois ans
d'avance sur la concurrence en termes de
performance au niveau de leur puce bon
je l'ai pas vérifié faudrait mesurer une
fois de plus c'est compliqué de venir
faire des benchmark avec notamment des
en tout et compagnie directement entre
l'iPhone et des smartphones Android mais
bon voilà en tout cas c'est leur
discours c'est un discours marketing il
est assez marrant je sais pas ce que
vous pensez de ces nouveaux iPhone moi
je suis très curieux j'ai très envie de
voir tout ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui avec la dynamic Island au
niveau des modèles professionnels je
trouve que les modèles aussi 14 sont pas
mal je trouve quand même cher pour voir
qu'on a pas la dernière puce oui
d'habitude on avait la dernière touche
que c'est quand même relativement cher
les tarifs s'envolent mais bon les specs
sont là les smartphones sont les champs
et intéressant je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez dites-moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire et puis nous on se retrouve
très vite pour continuer à parler bien
évidemment d'Apple continue à parler des
iPhone il y a plein de choses qui vont
arriver les tests les prises en main les
découvertes et puis il y a une vidéo
également que je vous sors pour vous
parler des Apple watch notamment la
nouvelle Apple watch ultra un monstre
qui emmène Apple encore plus loin au
niveau de la montre connectée ça c'est
une autre vidéo alors acheter un petit
coup d'oeil je vous embrasse prenez soin
de vous et à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]